en los suburbios de parís emanuel y su
hija de 6 años acogen desde septiembre a
una joven sin hogar por su seguridad y
la de su familia debe permanecer en el
anonimato
ella es una refugiada política murió de
su país a los 15 años cuando su hermano
fue asesinado aunque es temporal tener
donde vivir le permite seguir un curso
de francés aquí les muestro mis
lecciones a ver cuéntame está bien ella
fuma cigarrillos se ve tranquila sí
tranquila
la mayoría de personas sin hogar posee
un teléfono móvil lo que aprovecho la
asociación solid núm para crear la
aplicación llamada gracias por la
invitación una plataforma que une
anfitriones voluntarios y mujeres que no
tienen donde vivir
el invierno pasado me conmovió bastante
la situación de los migrantes así que
empecé a buscar en internet y encontré
esta aplicación yo vivo sola con mi hija
así que podía tener a alguien más en la
casa nos reunimos dos veces antes de que
ella viniera acordamos que viviría aquí
por un mes
y todo fue muy bien así que renovamos
hasta diciembre
el esposo y el bebé de esta mujer están
varados en egipto el logro de encontrar
trabajo pero ella no por eso decidió
hacer el viaje a europa en un bote
inflable durante 11 días y 11 noches
y quiero aprender francés ir a una buena
escuela traer a mi esposo y a mi bebé
aquí quiero tener libertad gracias a la
plataforma digital 37 mujeres sin hogar
son acogidas en francia por voluntarios